elles sont nombreuses à pouvoir
poursuivre leurs activités en
télétravail les entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines majoritairement dans
le secteur tertiaire ont remis en place
cette organisation spécialisée dans les
services de stockage informatique et de
cyber sécurité
antemeta décidé de mettre 110 personnes
en télétravail sur les 180 employés du
site de guyancourt
on a pris la décision avec l'ensemble
des membres du comité de direction de
généraliser le télétravail en assurant
une permanence pour les activités qu'il
était d'être continuer notamment nos
activités de sirk de monitoring
commercial et d'importation et de
maintenance chez nos clients pensent que
dans tous les cas le télétravail
enfin en tout cas le confinement change
les méthodes de travail pour l'avenir et
que le télétravail va forcément devenir
une petite d'orb en tout cas dans les
entreprises et nous on constate déjà
même dans nos entretiens de recrutement
qui effectivement l'école les candidats
nous pose la question
autre exemple avec d link france son
siège est installé dans le quartier de
l'hyper centre de montigny le bretonneux
aujourd'hui sur la vingtaine de
collaborateurs 17 poursuivre leurs
activités depuis leur domicile
il reste malgré tout des besoins de 30
ans de d'être au bureau on n'est pas
dans le même confinement que le premier
continent le premier confinement
l'activité s'était réduite de façon
assez importante
là c'est pas le cas pour l'instant donc
vallée besoin d'être bureau parfois
produit du côté du technocentre renault
le télétravail est aussi la règle
seulement 10% des onze mille salariés
sont actuellement présents sur le site
leur présence est nécessaire de par leur
mission l'activité sur des prototypes
sur des bancs d'essai ou les projets
urgents sur de futurs véhicules
avant ce nouveau confinement depuis le 7
septembre 2020 les collaborateurs du
technocentre télétravail et trois ou
quatre jours par semaine